there was an article recently about how
they're looking for redheaded sperm
donors and they put up I guess without
your permission
this is the article and they used your
picture yeah and I was thinking about it
and I was like that is a compliment
they're sort of saying you are the
example of the most beautiful redhead
well I think they're also presuming I
can produce birth pride on driver
occasion okay
EPS you guys make it no we have no
problem with that
it's just easily yes I don't know I lost
my train of thought no no no we don't
want to see that did you were you did
you like being a redhead growing up um
did you I mean I hate it
yeah I hate it I like it now though do
you like it now I like it better now
obviously I like it better but I had the
orange hair and the freckles and I was a
kid and I hated it
yeah yeah and I feel like recently I
actually dyed my hair blonde or I put a
picture of a blonde wig on and all my
sort of ginger friends turned against me
they don't now I feel like I found a
community of gingers we're dying out
we're going extinct never one of them
it's true that's oh that's really funny
isn't it based on our outfits alone no
we're going extinct and I think that's
why when one of us there's so few of us
when one of us decides to diet anyway
anyway it feels like a great betray
writers yeah traitors traitors yeah but
I've got the dark eyes you've got the
blue so you've probably more sun damage
I'm pretty lucky
you could push in and you'd see all the
sun damage you want it's true I do have
I know but I trust me I go to the
dermatologist every four hours yeah I
wear SPF 90 yes me too I shoot like back